ostentatious exaggerated colossal it
seems that Dubai always aspires to carry
out the largest most luxurious and most
eccentric projects in the world in this
small territory we can find tallest
building the most luxurious hotel and
even the largest international airport
on the planet located in a strategic
enclave at the mouth of the Persian Gulf
the growth process of Dubai is one of
the fastest in human history just over
20 years it has gone from being a remote
and lost Enclave in the desert to
becoming one of the world's great
capitals in this period of time the
emirate of Dubai has multiplied by for
its population by nine the number of
visitors hands by eight the size of its
economy but having said that the
question is how has all of this
development been achieved has it all
just been a matter of oil well in this
visual politic video we're going to talk
all about Dubai
dubai is one of the seven emirates that
make up the united arab emirates we
could describe its government as an
islamic autocracy that restricts a large
part of people's civil liberties however
if we compare it with neighboring
countries Dubai is by far the most open
place in the Middle East so how about
some examples well here women can drive
the veil is not mandatory you can buy
pork at the supermarkets and even
alcohol is not hard to come by
yes things are starting to change and in
a way I think we could refer to this
city as a kind of oasis in the middle of
the desert and as you can imagine all of
this change has had its rewards stands
well these rewards they might just
surprise you did you know that a to buy
is already the fourth most visited city
in the world when it comes to
international visitors and that it
surpasses epicenters of tourism and
global trade such as New York Hong Kong
or Singapore while it absolutely is and
this is something that does surprise a
lot of people of course there's one
thing we have to be clear on here Dubai
does not aspire to be the freest place
on earth but they do want to come their
richest
examples of opulence in this place are
so evident that it's not strange to see
the Dubai police patrolling the street
in Ferraris or Lamborghinis where else
in the world could you possibly see
something like this so you might at this
moment be thinking well there's an easy
explanation for all of this and that is
of course oil now could it be that Dubai
is nothing more than a sheiks dream
methodists financed with petrol dollars
well although we cannot deny the
influence of black gold here the truth
is that the real key to to buy success
is very different
the secret to Dubai is not oil but
rather its commitment to trade don't
believe me well let's dive in a little
deeper not enough oil
at the ends of the 1950's importance oil
deposits were discovered in the vicinity
of Abu Dhabi the capital of the Emirates
now take note here because we're not
talking about some small discovery but
an absolutely huge amount of oil to give
you an idea it is estimated that the
wealth of the Emirates their proven
reserves is even greater than all the
reserves in Russia however in the case
of Dubai things that were a little bit
different it is true that this territory
was also graced with the fortune of
black gold but its authorities soon
realized that their reserves were much
smaller than those of their compatriots
in Abu Dhabi in fact although it may
surprise us oil today accounts for less
than 1 in every $100 produced by devised
economy so you've probably heard about
how important it is do you diversify an
economy right well that is precisely
what Dubai did they overcame their
dependence and their addiction to oil
now this is all very easy to say but the
question is well how did they do it what
did Dubai do to achieve such development
and achieve a higher standard of living
even compared to its oil-rich neighbours
well basically what it did was attract a
whole bunch of multinationals and
professionals from all around the world
to achieve this the first thing they did
was bet on a low tax policy look in
Dubai they have no income tax the tax on
profits it's practically non-existent
and currently purchases are not taxed
either although the latter is about to
change as the result of a joint
agreement between all members of the
Persian Gulf Cooperation Council a tax
on purchases will soon be launched
however the rate is only gonna be about
5% which is significantly lower than the
rates we see in developed countries
which tend to be around 18%
and of course in case you were wondering
in Dubai there are no taxes on gasoline
yes I know it almost seems like we're
talking about another planet right but
do not think that low taxes are the only
strategy that Dubai has followed not at
all in fact seconds and perhaps even
more important than taxes Dubai has
resorted to an instrument known as
special economic zones although here
they are some more different to the ones
we can find elsewhere in the world in
Dubai these special areas in addition to
having tax benefits even have their own
regulations almost laws which as you can
imagine are always focused on promoting
business activity precisely thanks to
having specific rules companies can
escape the rigidity of legal systems
that are inspired by Sharia law
something that applies of course to the
rest of the Emirates
we can find a good example of this model
in the so-called Dubai International
Financial Center which is almost a state
within another state
look this financial center it even has
its own judicial system chaired by the
way by a British judge and it even has
its own official language which is not
Arabic but English and it's also
replaced the local currency with the US
dollar in this way a financial
institution the bank for example can do
business as if it was in Manhattan but
benefitting from the tax advantages of
Dubai a lot of our deal right
so well now we can probably understand
how Dubai has managed to attract most of
the 25 largest banks in the world but
this is not all along with low taxes and
special economic zones Dubai has also
opted for a very high degree of
immigration freedom and the result of
all this well 96 percent of its
inhabitants they've been born abroad but
wait a second because there is still
more now to further boost foreign
investment at the beginning of this
century the Dubai authorities made an
unprecedented decision for this corner
of the world
breaking balls 18002 government of Dubai
approved a risky decree that allows any
foreigner regardless of their religion
to make real-estate investments at that
moment the authentic boom it really
began
Dubai was full of buildings and large
projects hundreds of skyscrapers
gigantic shopping centers and even its
famous artificial islands now the demand
for Dubai became absolutely global it's
a fact that since 2002 Dubai has
experienced real estate developments
comparable only to that of Shanghai a
city with 13 times more inhabitants
indeed another one of the most
surprising things about Dubai is that it
has a population of less than 3 million
inhabitants just like this where before
there were only a handful of skyscrapers
thanks to this degree there are now
hundreds and huge projects are announced
one after the other be this new
skyscrapers Ferris wheels theme parks
whatever one of these latest projects by
the way is known as the mole of the
world it's a gigantic space designed to
become the largest shopping center in
the world and which will even house its
own cultural district with dozens of
theaters and cinemas 100 hotels and the
largest indoor theme park in the world
the project has been presented as the
world's first city with a temperature
controlled environment
while all of these measures have made to
buy a place where it is easy to do
business and have turned this emirate
into a commercial touristic financial
logistical and even industrial power yes
anyone who thinks that all Dubai is a
mouse is banks and hotels is very very
wrong nowadays Dubai largely thanks to
its modern ports and special zones is
the third largest react sporting power
in the world and its industrial
production exceeds 50 billion dollars
every single year
this is what explains why its neighbors
are uneasily watching any fall in the
price of oil while the governments of
Dubai continues to carry out a large
projects it is true from a strictly
political point of view that there
aren't many reprehensible elements when
it comes to religious social or human
rights issues for example there are the
painful conditions suffered by many
construction workers from countries such
as India Bangladesh or Pakistan now of
course we cannot ignore this reality but
we cannot not pay attention to the
achievements of this emirate among other
things because of this growth Dubai has
managed to influence the policies of its
neighbors and they are beginning to
reduce their dependence on oil as well
Dubai is quite simply a great model to
follow
considerate for example the new Saudi
Arabia under Mohammed bin Salman this is
something we actually spoke about in a
previous video anyway I think this case
puts a very important question on the
table is it possible to reconcile the
absence of civil rights with sustainable
economic growth over time now history
and empirical evidence seems to show
that this is not the case but in a world
increasingly pressured by very high
taxes and regulations of all kinds
Dubai's authorities seem intent on
demonstrating that this time it will be
possible at the moment its commitment to
free trade and investment and its
policies aimed at strengthening legal
security ease of doing business and
keeping taxes low have been superlative
if anything Dubai shows us the
competitiveness and freight tend to have
better results in terms of development
than protectionism or subsidies many
rulers should pay attention to these
successes of this oasis in the desert
but that's our opinion here a visual
politic and now we'd love to know what
you think do you think the debye model
will make the Middle East a freer place
well leave your answer in the comments
below as well as in this survey and I
really hope you did enjoy this video if
you did please do hit that like button
and do not forget to subscribe for brand
new videos every Monday and every
Thursday also please do check out our
friends at the reconsider Media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine and as always thank
you for watching